[ __ ] spacek was my mom what do you what
else do you want
[Music]
the year my voice broke it was gonna be
at Le movie almost called the year my
voice broke was actually called
reflections at that time that was it's
working title and travel Leishman was
kind of like the town bad-boy Trevor
would steal cars and drive around and
around the the racetrack until the car
ran out of petrol and then you know the
cops would be sort of standing there
this was in a country town and I would
be standing there waiting for him to run
out of petrol and try and arrest him
Trevor had a laugh that was very
distinctive which was John daigon
picking up on my sort of at that time he
kind of like silly kind of laugh like
that's the film that that that you know
made made it so that I made films
basically Spotswood known in America as
the efficiency expert you know he's a
working-class gormless boy working in
this Factory
he wants to kiss the pretty girl but he
doesn't quite know how to do it it has
the distinction of being Tony Colette's
first film it's one of the early films
with Russell Crowe in it and of course
it has Anthony Hopkins in the film that
he had made immediately after he made
Silence of the Lambs
Sansa lambs wasn't released by this
point but he had just made it
I probably learnt things on that job
from from Hopkins really that that have
stayed with me the most there was
something about his ethos and something
about the way he worked
he's a very you know gentle soft kind of
guy but you can see in his performances
this other world going on so I owe an
enormous debt of gratitude to him for
just transmitting that you know just
passing that stuff along more than
anything else so got that film means to
me
[Music]
Mullens
I like melon I like any mullet a lot
Eddie mullet is a guy that that comes
from a small town wants to leave all
these idiots behind him goes off to the
city burns out in one way or another and
returns home to this sleepy fishing town
oh she's still not talking to you just
cool mom and that's kind of what mullet
is now this is made by David Caesar and
Davy is someone incredibly important to
me because we go back to the beginnings
of both of our careers I did his student
film for him when he was still in school
and I think there's this incredible
lyricism in what he does they are really
deeply personally important films
Australia captain Dutton is meant to be
the sensitive of the sensible
alternative to Hugh Jackman's you know
vastly more appealing proposition for
Nicole Kidman's affections in Baz
Luhrmann's Australia if he's a slightly
sort of uptight proper a lot of people
think he's an English character even
Australians think he's an English guy
he's not he's an old it's an
old-fashioned what I was trying to do
was do an old the old Australian
upper-class speak which sounds very
similar to two British in a lot of ways
but anyway they didn't get picked up on
that's either my father or whatever I
felt awesome about doing a film for
bears Strictly Ballroom remains one of
the like it's absolutely it remains in
my top five most enjoyable experiences
I've ever had going to a cinema and of
course you know he's got that he's got
the secret weapon Midas cause it's got
Thelma shoot you know Thelma but you
know Baz has got cm as has got Catherine
Martin and that is like that's a combo
[Music]
Animal Kingdom Pope is the elder
statesman of a really very tough violent
Melbourne crime family there's a culture
there that that is a lot more about you
know guide a guy growing up it's a lot
more about being tough and not showing
stuff and having the sense of a threat
that you might hurt someone if they do
if they transgress in some way I'm
talking about my I just want you to tell
me things you know it just kills me to
see you living a little [ __ ] off
seriously
Davey misho I knew for a long time and
Davy Misha was a guy who wrote for a
film magazine and Davy wanted to make a
film and it was like a year what
you know sodas you know every year you
go on and Davi it's you know said I want
you to play this character and it's like
whatever or the good thing about you
know being around and being basically a
pessimist
you should get proved wrong a lot and I
love being wrong about stuff the animal
kingdom is without question the most
career wise important film that I ever
made
I mean without animal kingdom you I mean
you know you you don't give a [ __ ] about
me without that film because none of the
rest of this stuff happened
[Music]
the Dark Knight Rises this is the period
when I was like something's going right
something's really really going right
this meeting will now come to order
you know I think to point out that we
have an on board member here which is
highly irregular
even if his family name is above the
door Bruce Wayne's family built this
company and he himself has run into the
ground that was the first time I'd ever
been on a film set of the biggest movie
being made on the planet Earth at that
time and I was like no it's just like
it's pretty awesome I don't remember
much but dagger Don and particularly
care about Daggett in one way or another
you know what I mean I went in I flipped
a couple of burgers I tried not to
disgrace myself that was basically you
know there's very limited
you know stuff there's some boardroom
stuff going on in there and then there's
all that stuff of I've hired you to you
know to be my you know my guy and please
don't you know are you gonna hurt me oh
this is kind of confronting but remember
just being on set with like this
Christian Bale
this Morgan Freeman like and what I
really really really really remember
having reinforced is this games exactly
the same
doesn't matter if you're making the
crappiest most down and dirty shitty
kind of indie that no one's ever can in
the world see or you're making the
biggest movie on earth
[Music]
bloodline
I was skeptical and I was touched and I
was you know a little bit chuffed that
these guys came to me and said listen we
want to make a film a series part of me
about you know the black sheep of the
family and we want to kind of
investigate that dynamic and what it is
in a family and you know and they're
gonna kill him you know I never get
another De Niro but you know I mean like
you do one of those guys like there's a
few were these guys that you're never
going to get them again I'm never gonna
get another Pope I'm never going to get
another Trevor Leishman they you there
are certain things which for whatever
reason everything kind of forms up and
the thing in and of itself hits people
you know it people take it into their
hearts it becomes part of their life
they talk about it they enjoy it you
sent a load up the same way that I
didn't must took a teach what did you
take a detour
yeah I love Danny I I love love love
Danny rogue one a Star Wars story middle
manager as principal villain it's an
interesting idea I have peddled the line
and I will continue to peddle the line
that he is the man that built the Death
Star even though there's a very strong
argument that Mads Mikkelsen character
may have but you know [ __ ] it right I
mean you build the day you get a chance
to claim you built the Death Star I'm
taking it I'm running with it Star Wars
I mean you know I went there I watched
that film as a kid in in in Melbourne in
you know in the City Star Wars was just
like huge
I mean Gareth he approached me in this
sort of super secret meeting and I went
to the top of some Beverly Hills Hotel
and sat on the thing la la la and he
said you know I want you to play the
villain in this upcoming Star Wars movie
and I was like okay and I had to keep a
lid on it so like forever I mean when
Darth Vader turns up on a set yeah
director credit all data ready player
one that's the best screening of a film
that I've ever been to in my life
South by Southwest screening of ready
player one in Austin the first time
anyone ever got to see that film in the
public that is the wildest experience
and the best experience I ever had
watching a film miss Spielberg and
captions wife had had seen blood line
and we're fans and so essentially it's
blood line that gets me ready player one
when I got them to meet with them
Spielberg you know look I'm a fan of you
know I grew up I love all this stuff you
know I I still feel like a kind of a
fanboy nerd and I do pinch myself and
kind of get a bit blushy in a bit like
essentially you're dealing with it with
the film which you know is very very
largely in virtual reality that took an
enormous amount of time and discipline
so technically for him it's a really a
post-production piece but what it meant
for us in terms of the capture stuff is
is really kind of as usual but in this
sort of white blank space where you've
sort of got a plate and eat nd you know
I made pretend II about what's where and
whatnot that's the fastest most quick
crew I've ever seen in my life the the
Spielberg's crew is beyond and there's
no one that thinks in terms of camera
moving through stuff in real time that
I've ever seen there's no one there's no
one like you
[Music]
the sheriff is really you know political
modern political speaker kind of as you
know as villain sir surely the church
it's a law and orders you
I'm the law and order here I can't
afford to lose another penny so it's
been a bit since your last confession my
conscience is clear he's a modern kind
of political populist II type of you
know operative sleazebag dude you know
power power money money give it give it
it's really the way that Otto talked
about what he wanted to do with in the
world of hood that was kind of like the
[ __ ] and the world of Nottingham in
this piece which is an origin story
we're going to teach you things about
Rama hood you never even knew all right
cheep-cheep for the price of admission